-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
fitness fail stories
from you guys.
This first one
is from @TuckerSolteszta.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
This one's from @NikkiNombre.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh, this can't be right.
You would never order something
like this, would you?"
-"You got a lot
of Dunkin' on here."
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @zgholloway.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
The old steamroller move, yeah.
This one's from @jeanneredden.
She said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a standoff.
♪♪ Whee-ooh, whee-ooh ♪♪
This one's from @pascuamy.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hour here.
Hour there.
-"I'll do three hours now
of free time."
-"Yeah, I'm gonna eat
this pizza here."
-"And then I've got
21 more hours left."
-"Every week, baby"
-This one's from @laurabutler81.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Somebody stop and help me!
Somebody help me!"
-"It's just for show."
-"It's just for show, yeah."
This last one's
from @debraweber5.
She said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go.
Those are some of
the "Tonight Show" Hashtags
from you guys.
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.